the following contains images of graphic
violence your discretion is advised
you've probably heard about the tragic
death of Kelly Thomas in early July 2011
Thomas was a 37 year old schizophrenic
drifter who was allegedly beaten to
death by Fullerton California police
officers at this bus depot there were
probably at least six officers there
trying to subdue mr. Thomas having great
difficulty in so doing him while they
were trying to take him into custody but
you may not be aware of how the story
spread the death of Kelly Thomas is a
case study of how ubiquitous phones with
cameras and the internet are
transferring power from government
police and the media to the masses now
the story that might never have surfaced
if someone hadn't picked up his home
video camera we already know how
influential cameras could be on a police
encounter from the 1991 Rodney King
beating in Los Angeles the three police
officers facing felony criminal charges
were among a group of 15 who stopped a
25 year old black man last Saturday
night then beat him kicked him and
clubbed him unaware that an amateur
photographer was recording the incident
on video tape I was actually living in
the Los Angeles area in 1992 working for
the FBI during the Rodney King
videotaped incident Mike German is
policy counsel for the American Civil
Liberties Union in Washington and an
expert on surveillance
I think what's changed is technology has
developed so much so that we now carry
cameras and and/or video recorders on
our very person everywhere we go so it's
very easy to immediately pull them up
and take a video of whatever's happening
that's how this horrific video of the
Kelly Thomas incident was recorded
but it didn't air on the nightly news
right away like the Rodney King beating
in fact Ron Thomas Kelly's father told
us at the bus depot that after initial
interest the media stopped covering the
story nothing was going on
nobody wanted to pick it up I tried to
contact everybody nobody cared to do
anything but in the midst of his
frustration he made an important move at
the hospital maybe a couple hours after
being there and all of this is sinking
in
I took some cell phone pictures don't
know why I did it
don't have a clue of why I did I just
felt compelled I needed to take pictures
the former Orange County deputy captured
a picture so horrific it showed why the
media should pay attention so I released
the picture of my son that got
everybody's attention when a cell phone
video came out I released that the audio
had their attention again you put the
two together the picture with the sound
of what's happening it was very very
compelling
[Music]
the horrific video and picture came
after the Fullerton police decided not
to release any information they will not
say if they tased him since it's under
investigation and so far cannot comment
on whether excessive force was used
we're gonna conduct a thorough
investigation and if there were any
actions that weren't justified then that
will come out in that investigation the
Kelly Thomas case seems to be a case
study for what public information
officers and what law enforcement
agencies should not do
Jared Lovell is a criminologist at
California State University Fullerton
the police didn't release any
information they have not gone public
with their facts of the case they
haven't released the names of the
officers what we've seen since the event
is everybody commenting on the Kelly
Thomas case but the Fullerton police
Louisville has written about the
importance of public information in his
book good cop bad cop mass media and the
cycle of police reform public
information is essential so that people
can keep check on government this is
Sergeant Andrew Goodrich he's the public
information officer for the Fullerton
police in the Kelly Thomas case it
appears that the Fullerton public
information officer ceased to be a
public information officer and simply
has been a public relations officer for
the Fullerton police that being said not
a very good public relations officer for
the Fullerton police because without
releasing any information it makes the
agency look like it has something to
hide
we asked sergeant Goodrich to come on
camera and talk about his role in
providing information but he declined
our request
I believe the fact that the victim's
father Ron Ron Thomas was able to
release information before the public
information officer from a Florida
Department shows this shift in political
power at the local level from police to
the citizenry so citizens can
be the media themselves so now people
who are videotaping these incidents can
make their own editorial decisions and
put that information out into the
community and let the community decide
whether it's worthwhile and something
that means so when Ron Thomas released
the photo and video the community
erupted City Council meetings have been
packed with outraged citizens and
hundreds of people show up to rally
outside the Fullerton Police Department
we're here to stop Fullerton police
[Music]
eventually the story hit the national
and even international news this next
story started out with a video posted on
YouTube I have to warn you the picture
I'm about to show you is very graphic
the brutal death of a homeless man is
sparking outrage in the city of
Fullerton it's just as wrong with or
without the picture but sometimes the
picture helps people kind of realize
what happened even people at the rally
outside the police department told us
what in effect the Kelly Thomas images
had on them
you actually hear him calling out for
his dad it definitely did something to
my heart
cheering and seeing that the video is
definitely a great tool you know I think
everybody should always be recording not
just video but internet it's everywhere
and we don't have to wait for the news
to put it out so you really don't need
the media anymore you now have YouTube
you know have Facebook
you now have social media it really
shows that distribution of power away
from authority in this case away from
police authority and to the average
citizen to hold elected officials and to
hold government agents like this
technology is amazing and now they just
do you know they're not going to be able
to get away with what they used to be
able to get away with because of the
technology now they're under the watch
of us and we're gonna video them for
everything even if residents have
cameras someone was still inexplicably
lost and even if there are visual images
to keep the police accountable for what
happened at this bus depot those images
won't ever escape Ron Thomas listen to
my son babe those officers please please
God I'm sorry I'm sorry and then the
last words of his life
dad dad I wanted you to hear that first
in your life like I will
[Music]